(counter clicks)
(text chimes)
(upbeat guitar music)
(girls laugh)
(drum rolls)
- Hi.
Hi, I'm Mars, 23. I'm from New York.
You guys all look beautiful, by the way.
- [Crew Member] So if you
would swipe right on Mars,
you're gonna stay.
If you would swipe left, as in no,
exit the stage, come take a seat. Now.
(upbeat jazz music)
(hearts chime)
- That's the nicest thing
that's ever happened to me.
(girls aww)
(upbeat music)
- Hey, how you doing?
- I'm good. How are you?
- You nervous?
- A little bit.
- Not used to the attention?
- Not really.
(girls aww and laugh)
(bottle pops)
(girls laugh)
- Cheers.
- To Jubilee.
(girl imitates air horn)
- Cheers!
- Are you a drinker? Do you like to party?
- Sometimes. I travel a lot.
I do modeling. They take me places.
So I'm here to do some shoots.
- [Girl] That's awesome.
- Do you have a model face that you do?
- Show us the model face.
- I'll be honest, I do not.
There isn't one.
Most of it is just like you're talking
and then they take pictures
while you're doing stuff.
- [Jasmine] Like the natural style.
- Do they make you model shirtless?
(girls laugh)
- The thing is when
you audition for stuff,
most of the time you
can't have a shirt off.
- Can we get a preview?
- Yeah, let's get a preview.
- Listen, I got you guys later, okay?
Don't even worry about it.
- So being a model, do you date a lot or-
- Nah.
- What's your track record?
- Travel too much.
Even though I would love to
have a girlfriend, though.
- Is she in this room?
- I've had three girlfriends in my life.
All of them have been long-ish term.
So, like, two years.
- Wow. What's your Zodiac sign?
- I'm a Libra.
- [Azonde] What does that mean?
They say they're really nice.
They also say we're indecisive.
It's also kind of true.
- Well, we're gonna decide for you.
- Facts. That's why it
works for today, yeah.
I don't have to decide anything for real.
- So is there anything
thing you're looking
for in particular?
- Describe your type.
- Okay, not to be cliche,
physically, I don't
really have a type, but-
- That's lying. (laughs)
- I swear. Promise you.
There's three things I look for, though.
Hair, lips, and eyes.
- Classic body parts.
- But it's like, everyone
has those, so it's like...
(overlapping chatter)
- You gotta have nice lips,
nice eyes.
- Any of you guys have tattoos?
- [Group] Yeah.
- I do tattoos, though.
Would you let me tattoo you?
- I definitely would.
- My name starts with an E.
Would you let me tattoo-
- A E?
- An E on you?
- Where would you put it?
- Wherever you want.
I don't know. (laughs)
- What's your controversial opinion?
- Ooh, hot take.
I think that people hype
Zendaya up too much.
(record scratches)
(girls gasp)
- I could see that.
- That is offensive!
- No, she's great. She's phenomenal.
People put her on such a high pedestal.
I'm, like, she's-
- Do you not think she's attractive?
- No, she's cute.
- [Alondra] Okay. Okay.
- What do you think is
your biggest red flag?
- Ooh, yeah.
- Ooh.
- Okay, it's when someone's
rude to waiters and waitresses.
Super turn-off.
- I kinda wanna know what
everyone's red flag is.
- Go ahead. Go ahead.
- Lying for no reason.
- Having a big ego.
Like, if you're always right,
there's something wrong.
- You're right, you're right.
- Liars.
- Bad at communication.
- Well, I don't like controlling.
- Not owning up their mistakes.
- Definitely commitment issues.
- Kind of, like, ego.
- Wait, what's your ideal
type personality-wise?
- I do like to have fun.
I like to be the quiet half.
- Like you like to be there,
but not being too, like...
- I like to be, yeah. I
like to be mix adjacent.
- Well, I fell like we need
to decide if our ideal
type aligns with his.
- Oh, I was gonna say
what's your love language?
(girls ooh)
- That's a good question.
- I like physical touch.
I've noticed that because there's a lot
of people who I don't want touching me.
And so if I want you touching
me, it's like, oh yeah.
Act of service I do like.
When it seems like
someone's thinking about you
and so they do something
that's thoughtful,
that's really nice.
(text chimes)
(soft jazz music)
- Okay, so does anybody wanna stay?
- I'm definitely having fun.
- I'm vibin'.
- I think I'm feeling a
little vibe with Mars.
- So who absolutely does not
want to stay? Just right to it.
(girls laugh)
- Okay, we knew it.
- I like someone who's
a bit more outgoing.
- And I think I kind of want the guy
to lead the atmosphere and all that.
- Do you guys feel like he's funny?
- No.
- Not yet.
- That's a really big deal.
- If he was funny, he would've
made us laugh in that time.
- You're right.
- I'm just saying.
- I feel like he's probably just shy.
- Probably, though. Yeah, that too.
- Yeah, it's pretty intimidating.
I mean, I appreciate how
he said he's adventurous.
- Yeah. Oh that is true.
- Yeah, he travels.
(text chimes)
- Are we allowed to vote ourselves out?
- [Crew Member] You are
allowed to vote yourself out.
(girls sheesh)
- No, I was just asking.
I was just asking.
(mysterious jazz music)
- [Crew Member] So the girls
eliminated this round are
Kirsten and Cassidy.
(text chimes)
(girls aww)
(girls clap and laugh)
- Her skipping away. (laughs)
- You're like...
(upbeat jazz music)
- Hey.
- I'm Azonde.
- I'm Jasmine.
- (laughs) Alondra.
- Elen.
- Kennedi.
- Nice to meet you.
- I'm not gonna lie, I'm a little shy.
- I'm a little shy, too.
You probably can't tell.
(Paola laughs)
The first thing I noticed about
you is I like your outfit.
- Oh, thank you.
I chose it 'cause it
was bit of a power move.
- You play guitar.
- Yeah. I play piano more, though.
- Piano's hard.
- It is.
- So you're good with your hands.
- I would say so.
- Okay. That's cool. That's cool.
- Do you like to travel?
- I do love to travel.
When you said you're adventurous,
that's something I really
look for in a person.
- You know I was thinking
about it before when
you said tattooing a E-
- You would be down?
- Yeah, it would have to be
on my face. Like right here.
I don't know.
I just feel like for it
to really be meaningful,
it'd have to be on my face.
- Okay, cool. I feel like
that shows you're a committed person.
Should I get a Mars?
- Yeah. Get a planet.
- On my face, as well.
- Nah, you should get it right there.
- What's your thing that's
really embarrassing for you?
For me, I don't like falling in public.
- You know, it's gonna
sound kind of weird.
I don't really get embarrassed.
- Wow.
- If I were to fall, I
would just laugh at myself.
- But like eat (beep). Like fall.
- Yeah, even so I'd just be like, eh.
- What's your ring?
- It is a Chrome Hearts ring.
- Can I try it on?
- Okay, yeah. You have a big finger.
- Yeah. My fingers are kind
of thick. Not gonna lie.
- Do you like to workout?
- See, that's an interesting question.
Do I like to work out?
- Or do you have to work?
- I have to. But at this
point it's kind of a habit.
I do like feeling sore, though.
(record scratches)
If that, you know...
- So how'd you get your name?
Did you make it up yourself?
- Mars?
- Mm-hmm.
- Do you think I did?
- I think your friends did.
- Okay. I'm actually not gonna tell you.
- Why?
- Because it's a good secret.
Now I have something to talk about.
- I'm from Atlanta.
- I go to Morehouse.
- No way! Are you kidding?
Do you like it?
- It's cool.
- Better than New York or LA?
- Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
New York is the best city on earth.
LA is a close second.
- That's an opinion.
- It is an opinion, but
it's a strong one I have.
- I'm really into fashion.
I got this from the flea market.
- It's nice. But I do like fashion.
It's the first thing you see.
So I feel like you can tell a lot
about their personality
based off how they dress.
- So what can you tell
about my personality?
Oh, God. (laughs)
- You seem like you're fun.
- And what gives you that impression?
- I don't know. I really don't know.
It's like the whole thing.
- What are your biggest fears?
- I'll probably say being alone.
- Yeah.
- It's weird, though, 'cause
I'm kind of sort of a homebody
but I'm also really not.
But I'd rather be a
homebody not by myself.
- Completely get you.
I like watching Netflix and chilling,
but with a boo would be great.
- That's literally telling you.
- Oh.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you. (laughs)
- Nice meeting you.
- Bye, again.
(text chimes)
(upbeat jazz music)
- I think Jasmine is his bae.
- For real?
- For real.
- Dude, he immediately
asked you questions.
- You sat down and he was like, "So..."
- He had I'm ready for you.
- I think that he got along with you, too.
- Like you were making him nervous.
But also Alondra.
- Yeah, you guys have
like really good going.
With the flea market and all that stuff.
(text chimes)
(mysterious jazz music)
- I'm ready.
- [Crew Member] Do you feel like
they maybe made a good
choice? Are you nervous?
- A little bit.
But I feel like the choice
must have been good,
to be honest.
- One, two, three.
(chime plays)
- Jasmine!
- Oh, what was that? (chuckles)
How are you?
- I'm good. How are you doing?
- Did you expect me?
- Did I expect you? Low key.
- Low key.
Did you expect to be here?
- It was nervous, but maybe
the suit did something.
- [Crew Member] Mars,
I'm gonna hand you this.
- Oh, that's hilarious.
- [Crew Member] And I'm
gonna have you reveal
who you were selecting for yourself
after round two and round three.
- Well, for round two,
I had Jasmine, Elen, and Azonde.
- Oh, (beep).
- Period.
- For the last one,
I had
Jasmine.
(girls clap and cheer)
- Nice.
- That's funny.
What are the odds?
- I thought you didn't
pick me so I was like...
Are you gonna tell me
what your name means now?
- Oh, oh, oh yeah.
We can go on a date. I got you.
I'll tell you. I'll tell you about it.
- [Crew Member] So we think
there's a date in the future?
- Yeah.
(girls clap)
- We're happy.
- [Crew Member] Are we
all gonna be bridesmaids?
- Yes!
- [Kirsten] We talked about this earlier.
If someone gets married...
- Yeah, as long as y'all
pay for the wedding.
(calm jazz music)